schönen guten abend wir gehen live mit
zdf heute live und schauen heute abend
in die usa bundeskanzler scholz ist zum
antrittsbesuch bei us-präsident beiden
dass das aber kein normales erstes
treffen wo man mal schaut wie die
gemeinsamen zusammenarbeit aussehen
könnte und sich kennenlernt da wird es
heute gleich ans eingemachte gehen denn
es geht vor allem um den ukraine
russland konflikt und um die deutsche
haltung die ist den usa nämlich nicht
eindeutig genug wir werden sehen wie
sich kanzler scholz positioniert jetzt
gleich um viertel nach neun soll es eine
pressekonferenz geben mit stolz und mit
präsident biden
und die werden wir live übertragen und
dann zusammen mit markus kaim von der
stiftung wissenschaft und politik
einordnen und mit unserer usa
korrespondentin inna nieder niebergall
und die hoffe ich jetzt auch zu sehen
hallo nina grüße dich schönen guten
abend
hallo nina da kommt der deutsche kanzler
zum ersten mal nach washington und das
könnte ja eigentlich auch alles so schön
sein nach diesen vier schwierigen jahren
mit trump und jetzt gerät er gleich in
die defensive wegen seiner haltung und
weil es heißt dass deutschland kein
zuverlässiger bündnispartner sei es gibt
auch durchaus bessere voraussetzungen
für sein erstes date
die voraussetzungen sind in der tat
schwierig und olaf scholz hat auch
versucht den eindruck zu zerstreuen hat
der washington post zum beispiel ein
interview gegeben in dem er sagte es
handele sich um gerüchte das verhältnis
zwischen den usa und deutschland sei gut
es sei intakt aber fakt ist eben hier
wird laut kritik geäußert in den
amerikanischen medien und die entzündet
sich vor allem an zwei punkten
erstens die waffenlieferungen da sagt
deutschland ja inzwischen es werden
keine waffen geliefert in die ukraine
und deutschland erlaubt beispielsweise
auf estland nicht waffen die
ursprünglich mal zu deutschland gehörten
weiter in die ukraine zu liefern da gibt
es hier in den usa viel unverständnis
für vor allem wird auch häufig die frage
gestellt wie sieht es denn mit
rüstungsexporten aus deutschland
exportiert ja beispielsweise auch
rüstungsgüter nach saudi arabien oder
nach ägypten
das ist also kritikpunkt nummer eins
kritikpunkt nummer zwei es sind
wirtschaftssanktionen da ist scholz und
die deutsche bundesregierung den usa zu
unkonkret vor allem wenn es um die
gaspipeline nord stream 2 geht scholz
hat mehrmals gesagt es liegen alle
möglichkeiten auf dem tisch aber was
heißt das konkret er spricht die
gaspipeline nicht konkret an und das
wünscht man sich hier in den usa anders
unser kollege benjamin daniel hat den
usa besuch von scholz begleitet und
zusammengefasst wir schauen uns das
jetzt mal kurz ab
dass man hier nur fluggeräusche und
nicht etwa den kanzler sprechen hört hat
seine richtigkeit
hintergrundgespräch mit journalisten auf
dem flug nach washington
es ist alles andere als der usa routine
antrittbesuch den sich ein neuer
bundeskanzler wünschen könnte die reise
überschattet von der ukraine krise
scholz äußerte sich noch vor seinem
treffen mit joe biden es wird einen sehr
hohen preis haben wenn es dazu kommt
dass die ukraine militärisch angegriffen
wird und wir bereiten das auch präzise
vor und sind seit langer zeit dabei die
details dazu zu besprechen denn es geht
ja dann darum schnell zügig und
entschlossen zu handeln und vor allem
einheitlich amerika scheint nicht sicher
zu sein was es vom neuen bundeskanzler
halten soll das liegt auch am
zögerlichen verhalten berlins in der
ukraine krise während die usa tausende
truppen entsenden und waffen liefern bot
deutschland bisher 5000 helmer an dass
die verteidigungsministerin just heute
verkündet 350 weitere soldaten nach
litauen zu schicken ist sicher kein
zufall
und dann gibt's mit nord stream zwei ja
noch die dauer differenz zwischen den
usa und deutschland
außerdem weitere wichtige punkte dann
gibt es natürlich auch um die enge
ökonomische zusammenarbeit zwischen den
usa und deutschland und natürlich auch
darum wie wir die große weltweite
aufgabe bewältigen den menschengemachten
klimawandel aufzuhalten
da gibt es viel zu besprechen gerade im
rahmen der g7 präsidentschaft die
deutschland jetzt hat der bundeskanzler
wird in wenigen minuten mit dem
us-präsidenten im weißen haus sprechen
sie werden also viele themen diskutieren
ganz oben steht nicht weniger als der
frieden in europa
und diese gespräche laufen jetzt schon
seit einer weile und direkt davor haben
beide ja nochmal ihre verbundenheit
betont und joe biden hat davon
gesprochen dass deutschland einer der
engsten verbündeten amerikas sei scholz
sagte wir sind engste verbündete und
arbeiten intensiv zusammen
warum ist es den beiden so wichtig diese
dieser harmonie zu betonen wenn die
differenzen ja doch eigentlich relativ
groß sind
natürlich sind beide gehören beide zur
nato und das ist es gehört zur strategie
der usa eine geschlossenheit der nato zu
demonstrieren gegenüber russland und
putin und deutschland wird hier in den
usa ich habe vorhin schon die
medienberichterstattung angesprochen
häufig dargestellt als das schwächste
glied in der nato und dieser eindruck
den den möchten vor allem die die usa
nun zerstreuen sie wollen zeigen dass
auch deutschland an der seite der usa
steht gegen putin und das eben beide
ganz klar demonstrieren wenn russland in
die ukraine einmarschiert dann handeln
wir geschlossen wie nah es gibt eine
amerikanische zeitung die hat
deutschland ein armseliges exemplar
eines verbündeten genannt das sind ja
durchaus karte worte ist dieser image
schaden tatsächlich so pro
es ist alleine schon ganz interessant
dass in den amerikanischen medien im
moment so viel über deutschland
berichtet wird wie ich das im
vergangenen jahr hier nicht erlebt habe
und zwar von linken medien bis rechten
medien wird da deutliche kritik geäußert
du hast es gerade schon gesagt wirklich
auch in harschen worten man muss
natürlich sagen dass olaf scholz hat es
schwer mit seinem antrittbesuch er ist
nach 16 jahren kanzlerschaft von angela
merkel wieder ein anderer bundeskanzler
das sowieso schon mal dann ist ja ein
bundeskanzler der spd und er hat sich
bislang wenn es nach den amerikanern
geht etwas zu wenig geäußert zu unklar
geäußert das heißt die us-amerikaner
innen wissen einfach nicht genau wie sie
ihn einordnen sollen also ja der image
schaden würde ich sagen der ist da ist
sind zumindest schwierige
voraussetzungen
startvoraussetzungen für olaf scholz und
es wird eben wir darüber gesprochen von
mangelnder bündnistreue es wird darüber
gesprochen ob vielleicht emanuel makro
der französische präsident die rolle von
angela merkel in europa einnehmen kann
und das sind natürlich alles dinge die
gehören sich erstmal schwierig an
oder scholz scheint es allerdings
bewusst zu sein dass es diesen
imageschaden gibt und er möchte ihn
reparieren nach dem interview mit der
washington post bitte auch sie in ein
interview geben und er wird heute abend
auch mit senatorinnen aus dem
amerikanischen kongress zusammenkommen
zu einem abendessen
wie nah wir sehen gerade haben wir schon
ein bild von der pressekonferenz bekommt
die noch nicht begonnen habt aber
journalistinnen und journalisten
fotografinnen und fotografen kommen so
langsam rein und wenn sich der saal dann
gefüllt hat dann hoffen wir dass es auch
relativ schnell losgehen wird gegen
viertel nach neun wie gesagt soll die
pressekonferenz beginnen aber das ist
bei so mächtigen und großen politikern
und politikerinnen dann immer die frage
ob die sich auch so an den zeitplan
halten immer noch eine andere frage an
dich jetzt ist ja durchaus ein vorwurf
dass olaf scholz in den usa bisher noch
nicht so richtig sichtbar war und das
ist ja auch durchaus eine kritik die er
sich in deutschland anhören also was
erwarten die usa jetzt konkret von ihm
ich glaube dass die usa war genau das
von ihm erwarten klarheit kommt also
dass er konkreter wird und dass gilt
glaube ich für die amerikanische
öffentlichkeit genauso wie für die
us-regierung er sprach bislang davon
dass alle dinge auf dem tisch liegen er
hat nord stream zwei als
sanktionsmöglichkeit nicht konkret
genannt ich glaube dass die amerikaner
von ihm erwarten werden da einfach
genauer genaue dinge zu nennen was was
deutschland da tun wird und das wird
jetzt eben auch gleich bei der
pressekonferenz interessant werden
zusehen wie konkret werden die beiden da
also auch joe biden werden sie einen
sanktionskatalog vorlegen und was wird
dieser sanktionskatalog enthalten und
liebe nina du wirst uns weiter begleiten
und bei uns bleiben und nachher eben
auch nach der pressekonferenz die
informationen mit uns sortieren und
einordnen vielen dank für den moment und
heute reden nicht nur scholz und beiden
miteinander sondern auch außenministerin
baerbock sie ist heute in die ukraine
gereist und hat da weitere gespräche
geführt und noch mal betont dass die
territoriale unversehrtheit der ukraine
für deutschland quasi unantastbar ist
und dass ein totales no-go wäre daran in
russland daran irgendetwas rütteln würde
ebenso hat auch frankreichs präsident
makro den russischen präsidenten putin
besucht
und hat auch noch einmal für verständnis
geworben für die sorgen und nöte die im
präsident putin dargestellt hat und
es wurde auch besonders eben
betont dass man eben zuerst nach
russland gereist ist und dann in die
ukraine ich möchte jetzt markus kaim von
der stiftung wissenschaft und politik in
die runde holen heim zu ihren
schwerpunkten gehören die deutsche
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik und
eben die transatlantischen sicherheits
beziehungen guten abend herr kaim
der keim kann sie mich hören ja ich kann
sie hören
dann können wir auch direkt loslegen
das heißt auch immer also solange noch
geredet wird wird nicht geschossen und
jetzt wird er zu beginn der woche auf
vielen verschiedenen ebenen geredet
sehen sie das als gutes zeichen
es ist eher neutral wir sehen dass die
internationale krisendiplomatie an
temperatur gewonnen hat oder an fahrt
aufnimmt sie haben die eckpunkte und die
reisediplomatie gerade angesprochen und
der anlass dafür ist eigentlich kein
positiver weil die kriegsgefahr wenn man
auf die nackten zahlen schaut eher
zugenommen hat wir gehen im moment davon
aus nach auskünften westlicher
geheimdienste das 120.000 soldaten an
der ukrainischen grenze stehen russische
soldaten es gibt keine indizien dafür
dass der russische präsident
von invasions plain welcher
größenordnung auch immer da muss man
sehr vorsichtig sein abstand genommen
hat die eskalation wird weiter getrieben
von der russischen seite von daher muss
man sagen die krisendiplomatie der
vergangenen wochen hat bisher kenne ich
die gewünschten ergebnisse gezeitigt und
dementsprechend ist es nachvollziehbar
dass das ganze jetzt an fahrt gewinnt um
die berner seiner rückkehr wird ja der
bundeskanzlerin berlin sich mit immer
neuen treffen und den polnischen
präsidenten du dahin zu ziehen die
anderen baustellen an die gerade
angesprochen und alle setzen darauf dass
dort zu einer lösung des konfliktes
kommt aber dass es zumindest gelingt
ihnen so einzuhegen das sind nicht
militärische eskaliert
ich möchte an dieser stelle noch kurz
sagen wenn sie liebe userinnen und user
eine frage oder ein statement loswerden
wollen dann schreiben sie das bitte in
die kommentare falten oder schicken sie
uns auch gerne eine mail wie sie jetzt
eingeblendet sehen so hat das zum
beispiel tim gemacht und ich möchte ihm
sein statement mal kurz vor lesen er
sagt ich habe die erwartungen die usa
und deutschland mit dem vorschlag an die
presse herr antreten
wirtschaftssanktionen gegen russland
präventiv erlassen zu wollen wie
wirkungsvoll wäre das
das ist
nachvollziehbar vorschlag der auch
gerade von der ukrainischen regierung
immer wieder gefordert wird ich finde
ihn problematisch aus verschiedenen
gründen erstens wir können nicht ein
akteur bestrafen für dinge die ihr noch
nicht getan hat es wäre widersinnig ist
eine eskalation sluiter anzudeuten
gegenüber der russischen seite also
jemand in der abfolge wenn dieses oder
jenes passiert dann wird dieses oder
jenes tolle konsequenzen haben genau wie
der bundeskanzler dass gerade eben auch
in dem ausschnitt bekannt gegeben hat
und davon jetzt zugleich abzuweichen und
präventiv sanktionen zu verhängen zum
zweiten kommt hinzu
zum teil müssen sich diese sanktion vor
europäischen gerichtshöfen bewahren
können bewähren können das heißt
einzelne betroffene können klage erheben
und werden zu recht darauf verweisen
dass ja noch kein sachverhalt dafür
besteht wieder die sanktion unseren
dritter würde ich denken dass im moment
die deutsche auch die europäische
politik darum bemüht ist sich möglichst
große handlungsspielräume zu erhalten
und die würden erheblich reduziert wenn
man jetzt schon gegen vertreter der
russischen regierung oder oligarchen
oder russische firma das was diskutiert
wird sanktion verhängen würde das würde
doch die möglichkeiten der deutschen
diplomatie enorm einschränken und
niemand diese drei aspekte zusammen dann
wird glaube ich klar weshalb das kein
gangbarer weg im moment für die
bundesregierung ist
kein
mohammed hat eine frage auf facebook er
schreibt deutschland ist ein
europäisches land und muss sich für
europäischen frieden stark machen mit
russland kann man die probleme ohne
amerika friedlich lösen wir brauchen
keine kriege mehr in europa und in der
welt
meinen sie dass das möglich ist so einen
konflikt ohne die usa zu lösen
sind der wichtigste
sicherheitspolitische verbündete
das republik und das seit 70 jahren
stünde natürlich der bundesregierung
frei die nato zu verlassen was zur folge
hätte dass die amerikanischen truppen
den die bundesrepublik verlassen würden
und ihr heil in einer neuen
sicherheitspolitischen allianz mit
russland zu suchen so hab ich das jetzt
mal verstanden
mir scheint das kein gangbarer weg zu
sein weil sofern wir mal auf die werte
dimension der deutschen außenpolitik
schauen die ja gerade mittelpunkt von
vwr box aktivitäten steht da sehe ich
dadurch wenig aufeinander liegende
ordnungsvorstellungen ja das wird im
autoritären staat zu tun wo die
bundesrepublik wo die bundesrepublik
sich zum ziel gesetzt hat
rechtsstaatlichkeit und demokratie in
der welt zu verbreiten wir haben es mit
einem revisionistische staat zu tun mit
russland der die territoriale ordnung
europas in frage gestellt etwas was der
bundesrepublik heilig ist aus
vielfältigen historischen und
politischen gründen ich sehe da so wenig
berührungspunkte so dass ich nicht sehen
könnte wie russland die usa als
sicherheitspolitischer kann gelernt für
deutschland ersetzen könnte
es ist davon auszugehen dass kanzler
scholz jetzt nochmal gleich betonen wird
das deutschland selbstverständlich ein
verlässlicher partner ist und zum team
nato gehört welche auswirkungen hat so
ein bekenntnis dass er eigentlich klar
ist aber offensichtlich in diesen zeiten
immer und immer wieder gesagt werden
muss dann eben noch einmal auf
diplomatischer ebene
vorgeschichte hat als unzuverlässige
verbündeter zu gelten innerhalb der nato
was geht mindestens zurück bis zur
libyen operation der nato 2011 an der
die bundesrepublik nicht beteiligt hat
das ging weiter über den streit mit der
regierung trump über die 40 über die
höhe der verteidigungsausgaben seitdem
kursiert in washington deutschland sein
und zuverlässige verbündeter ein
trittbrettfahrer wie es immer heißt das
läuft alles mit bei dem eindruck gehen
wir eben gehört haben aus wort hängen
und von daher jetzt ganz wichtig dass er
genauso denn erstens noch einmal der
transatlantischen einheit und das aus
dem munde des bundeskanzlers zu hören
und zweitens wird der amerikanische
präsident dem bundeskanzler und
verständig unmissverständlich
klargemacht haben dass er erwartet dass
oder falls europa anführt das tut um
manuell makro aber das ist nicht die
erwartete und ja usa die usa fokussieren
auf deutschland als politisch ökonomisch
wichtigste macht in europa und das ist
ja auch was ihm angesprochen worden
bezüglich nord stream zwar auch ein
schlüsselakteur wenn deutschland hier
den schulterschluss mit den usa nicht
sucht in großbritannien unter bereiche
nord stream dann führt das eben auch zu
friktionen zwischen deutschland und den
usa und die usa bin ich dazu sagen
brauchen deutschland für ihr russland
politik und das wird ja das wird die
zentrale erwartung sein die der
amerikanische präsident heute formuliert
haben wird wäre das denn eine denkbare
option für die usa das wenn das alles
nicht so läuft wie sie sich das
vorstellen dass daneben frankreich diese
dieser führende partner in europa wird
formuliert es mal so im moment
hinterlässt die bundesregierung ein
führungsvakuum europa was der
französische präsident sehr geschickt
füllt er tut das in einer traditionellen
weise europa und europäische führung das
ist eine alte ordnungsvorstellungen der
französischen seite und versucht sich
als sprecher europas zu präsentieren
das tut er nicht ganz zu unrecht im
erstens weil frankreich mitglied des
neuen formats ist also das verhandlungs
format deutschland frankreich russland
ukraine mit dem man versucht hat den
ukraine konflikt im osten des landes ein
segen ist zurzeit präsident des
europäischen rates das heißt er spricht
automatisch für europa macht sich das
zunutze und und dass davon profitierte
persönlich im moment steht er im
präsidentschaftswahlkampf in frankreich
und kann alles das was er außenpolitisch
erreicht innenpolitisch für sich in
stellung bringen und das erklärt deshalb
im alkohol ganz so präsent ist heute in
moskau gewesen ist und in den augen der
usa als der führer europa erscheint und
warum hat die bundesregierung spricht
mit dem kanzler olaf allstar nicht im
frühjahr gegengesteuert das kann nicht
im interesse deutschlands seien diese
entwicklung
ist für den bundeskanzler endlich ganz
einfach das muss man dazu sagen er kommt
aus einer partei die in ihrer
russlandpolitik bis in die jüngste zeit
zerstritten ist das sehen wir jetzt in
diesen tagen ganz deutlich es gibt eine
traditionelle pro russische fraktion das
geht zurück bis auf willy brandt und
egon bahr eine gewisse romantische
vorstellung dass deutschland in
besonderer art und weise verbindungen zu
russland unterhalten würde und es gibt
eine jüngere generation die das rezept
die wir für angemessen hält dann habe es
mit der bundesregierung zu tun dass er
so die zweite ebene die nahostpolitik
mich nicht von einem blatt sinkt wenn
ich das so sagen darf wir haben die spd
mit dem position nicht gerade besprochen
habe wir haben die grüne außenministerin
die sehr frühzeitig gesagt dass sie
wieder bereit nord stream zwei zur
disposition zu stellen die werte
basierte außenpolitik machen will und
einen dialog mit härte verknüpfen wir
gegenüber russland ging also eine ganz
andere politik und werden die fdp die
sanktionen sehr kritisch gegenübersteht
war sie eben folgewirkungen für die
deutsche wirtschaft hätten vor diesem
hintergrund ist es schwierig finden
kannst da hier eine einheitliche optik
der deutschen politik zu präsentieren
und dann kommt die dritte ebene der
zerstrittenheit hinzu die europäische
das wäre auch hinzufügen dass europa von
den grundproblemen steht nicht mit einer
stimme zu sprechen wenn es um russland
geht wir haben es mit einer fülle von
russland politiken so muss man es so
formulieren im plural zu tun die von
unterschiedlichen europäischen
regierungen unterschiedlich vertreten
werden da gibt es die gruppe innerhalb
gerade osteuropas die sehr furchtsam
skeptisch auf russland gucken es gibt
frankreich war seit jahren unter immer
nur
versucht einen strategischen dialog über
die sicherheitsarchitektur europas zu
initiieren und deutschland etwa in der
mitte zwischen diesen beiden positionen
aber wenn man nicht spricht runterzieht
spricht europa nicht mit einer stimme
und in diesem in diesem
koordinatensystem soll der bundeskanzler
jetzt europa zusammenhalten deutschland
zusammenhalten und führungen an den tag
legen ich finde die erwartung durchaus
berechtigt aber es ist nicht ganz
einfach
wir sehen die ganze zeit den presseraum
im weißen haus und wir sehen dass sich
der raum gefüllt hat mit journalistinnen
und journalisten aber weder us-präsident
beiden noch kanzler scholz bislang vor
die presse getreten sind das soll jetzt
gleich passieren und da kam sie wissen
dann auch bescheid falls ich sie rede
unterbrechen muss weil wir dann gleich
nach washington geben
bis dahin aber noch eine frage von diana
sie haben gerade die sanktionen
angesprochen und die hat uns eine mail
geschickt und würde gerne wissen was
bedeutet wirtschaftliche sanktionen
gegen russland dann für uns deutsche
bürger das lässt sich im moment nicht
konkret beantworten es gibt eine reihe
von sanktionen dieser 2014 gegenüber
russland gelten gegenüber bestimmte
sektoren gegenüber bestimmten personen
gegenüber bestimmten
firmen alles als reaktion auf die
annexion der creme und die viel
stabilisierung der ost ukraine
jetzt hören wir der bundeskanzleramts
immer noch mal gesagt es seien weitere
eine weitere runde von sanktionen
vorbereitet oder in vorbereitung
und er lässt sich nicht dazu verlocken
konturen dieser sanktion auf den tisch
zu legen das kann man beschlägt oder
ungeschickt führen natürlich gar nicht
bewerten aber dementsprechend gewisses
einig und die größte frage ist ja die
wird das nord stream 2 geben wird den
will diese pipeline die ihr fertig
gestellt ist in betrieb genommen aber
dass die darauf zielen die frage der
zuschauerin letztlich ist nicht
auszuschließen dass das konsequenzen für
die bundesrepublik hat und auch die
außenministerin hat dass sie einen
aussicht gestellt nicht freudig im aber
zumindest gesagt
den sanktionen wirksam sein sollten dann
müssen sie massiv sein gegenüber
russland und das hätte eben auch zur
folge dass das konsequenzen für
deutschland haben könnte das könnte den
energiesektor betreffen das könnte
umsatzverluste von deutschen firmen
betreffen das könnte vieles andere
betreffen in das ist im moment mehr zu
als zu wissen aber die bundesregierung
das zumindest nicht ausgeschlossen
bleiben wir bei nordstream zwei darüber
sie haben es gesagt der kanzler mag da
nicht deutlich drüber reden aber es ist
doch eigentlich es ist doch logisch dass
dieses projekt dann sofort irgendwie
zumindest mal unterbrochen werden müsste
wenn daneben russische panzer
ukrainisches gebiet betreten würden was
warum hat er da diese zurückhaltung
auf den punkt zurück gehen ich eben
angesprochen habe wir hören aus der
regierungskoalition dazu
unterschiedliche stimmen die grünen
artikulieren sich da am deutlichsten
sehr kritisch dahingehend genau so genau
wie es gerade gesprochen angesprochen
haben sobald der erste russische soll da
die ukrainische grenze überschritten
habe sei nord stream hinfällig
würde nicht in betrieb genommen andere
sind dort zurückhaltender auch der
bundeskanzler hat ihren positionswechsel
insofern vorgenommen er hat noch im
herbst unmittelbar nach der wahl
geäußert er stünde in der linien seiner
amtsvorgängerin die ja auch nur zweimal
als rein ökonomisches projekte
beschrieben hat mitarbeiter bewertet ihr
die politische oder geopolitische
dimension des projektes anders und
versteht stärke und betont auch der ak
die politischen implikationen war es das
für den tag iks wirklich hieße das ist
aus heutiger sicht nicht zu beurteilen
ich schaue noch mal in den chat welche
fragen wir noch haben es gibt noch eine
frage von antonio er möchte gerne wissen
verfolgt putin wirklich ein ziel der
sicherheit immerhin müsste er doch auch
merken dass sein handeln bisher das
gegenteil von dem gebracht hat was er
immer fordert
da zuschauern ganz wichtigen punkt
es gibt mehrere hinweise dass wirklich
die die letzten wochen lässt sich
kontraproduktiv für die russische
politik gewesen denn ich will ein paar
beispiele illustrieren
letztlich hat niemand ernsthaft in der
nato noch über nato-beitritt der ukraine
gesprochen das ist 2008 auf dem gipfel
beschlossen worden aber nicht mehr
wirklich verfolgt worden jetzt steht es
wieder auf der tagesordnung
präsident putin hat deutlich gemacht
dass kein europäischer staat mehr
mitglied der nato werden solle kein
zusätzlicher mehr was sehen wir dass
staaten die eigentlich neutral sind wie
schweden und finnland gerade sich
stärker auf die nato zu bewegen
präsident putin hat deutlich gemacht
dass er keine truppen verstärkung der
nato in osteuropa dulden würde was sehen
wir genau das dass frankreich truppen
verlegt heute hat die bundesrepublik
angegeben die bundesregierung
angekündigt weiter 350 soldaten eine tat
zu entsenden die usa verstärkt ihre
truppenpräsenz in polen und andere als
das sind alles indizien dafür dass genau
das nicht passiert was er bild und ist
kontraproduktiv ist und es ist aus
heutiger sicht natürlich müßig darüber
zu spekulieren dass wir präsident putin
wirklich im moment
leuchtet mir angesichts dieser
kontraproduktiven effekte nicht ein was
er gewinnen würde wenn er die ukraine
wirklich vollständig besetzt ich setze
er darauf dass ihr vor allem auf eine
neuordnung der sicherheitsarchitektur
europas abzielt dass wir ja auch in
deckung zu bringen mit den russischen
vorschlägen vom dezember wo sie
bestimmte fragen und ultimaten an die
nato und an die usa gestellt haben wie
sie sich die europäische sicherheits
ordnung vorstellen und ich glaube das
bemühen der russischen seite ist im
moment mit militärischen drohgebärden
politische konzessionen zu erzielen mir
leuchtet noch nicht wirklich ein was er
durch eine militärische invasion oder
der stabilisierung der ukraine wirklich
gewinnen würde ja es gibt so manche
punkte die am vielen nicht einleuchten
costa tinos schreibt auf facebook
ich verstehe nicht wie man vor die
kameras treten kann und laut sagt man
stehe hinter der ukraine allerdings ist
man nicht bereit defensivwaffen für die
verteidigung der ukraine zu entsenden
ist das also die bedeutung der
solidarität dass es eben auch sein punkt
der vielen nicht klar ist und am den sie
nicht nachvollziehen können ja das ist
sicher ein schwachpunkt der deutschen
argumentationen im letzten wochen
einerseits immer solidarität zu betonen
und da will ich nicht unfair seien auch
zu recht zu betonen dass deutschland die
ukraine in den letzten jahren und 1,8
milliarden euro unterstützt hat die
transformation der ukraine
wirtschaftlich politisch den westkurs
der ukraine unterstützt hat und
gleichzeitig jetzt in einer solchen
situation
ist ein militärischer solidarität fehlen
ist wir verstärken oder wie die
bundesregierung verstärkt truppen in
litauen das ist eine beruhigung für die
staaten osteuropas die bereits mitglied
der nato geworden sind das hilft der
ukraine aber auch nicht und die
geschichte die sie ansprechen mit den
5000 m ich glaube die wir die
bundesregierung gerne ungeschehen machen
das ist ja ein kommunikatives desaster
gewesen da wäre man glaube ich besser
beraten gewesen gar nichts zu liefern
hat diese 5000 helme über die sich ja
die deutsche öffentlichkeit wenn ich das
so sagen darf nicht zu unrecht lustig
gemacht hat weil tatsächlich eine
ausdruck einer kraftvollen solidarität
in dieser zeit wo militärische
unterstützung auch vor erforderlich wäre
was nicht und die bundesregierung hat
sich weitgehend isoliert so muss man das
sagen zumindest unter den größeren
maschinen der nato weil da gibt es doch
einen so gut wie keinen anderen mehr der
nicht ausrüstung liefert den nicht
ausbildung in der ukraine macht und das
ist glaube ich so eine der baustellen
die dafür verantwortlich sind für das
für diesen für dieses bild oder diese
wahrnehmung der bundesrepublik die wir
ganz am anfang thematisiert haben als
und verlässlicher verbündeter
das wird ja diese zurückhaltung wird ja
oft mit der deutschen historie begründet
nun mehren sich aber auch stimmen die
sagen und dieses argument zählt so nicht
mehr
wie sollte sich deutschland da verhalten
einwände gegen warf liefern die ukraine
vor erstens das klassische deutsche
argument wie liefern ich in
krisengebiete stimmt ihr so gar nicht
wie liefern oder die bundesrepublik
liefert seit 70 jahren beim waffen an
israel und krisengebiet sondergleichen
2014 hat die bundesregierung waffen an
die irakischen kurden geliefert im
kontext des kampfes gegen den
islamischen staat
krisengebiet in dem modell
geschossen menschen haben also von daher
ist das auch so ein selbstbild das
genauere prüfung gar nicht standhält und
konkret auf die ukraine kann man das
lautet das argument ja immer oder sehr
häufig wo deutscher soldat im zweiten
weltkrieg gestanden hätten durften
deutsche waffen heute nicht hin
geliefert werden das argument lässt sich
genauso umdrehen 8 millionen ukraine
sind durch deutsche soldaten
im zweiten weltkrieg zu tode gekommen
und gibt daraus ließe sich ja eigentlich
ableiten oder gleichermaßen ableiten
dass dir das die bundesrepublik als
rechtsnachfolgerin des deutschen reiches
in besonderer weise verantwortung zu
tragen hat für die für das wohlergehen
der ukraine von daher ist die diese
bezugnahme auf das leid der sowjetunion
stellt russland in besonderer weise in
den mittelpunkt bleibt aber
eindimensional und blendet das
ukrainische leid das ukrainische ihnen
tauss
wir schauen noch einmal in den
presseraum und sehen dass die us presse
sprecherin des weißen hauses jetzt platz
nimmt vorne links auch der deutsche
regierungssprecher hat sich hingesetzt
das heißt die erste reihe fühlt sich
jetzt so langsam deshalb gehen wir davon
aus dass die pressekonferenz jetzt
vielleicht doch mit
knapp 20-minütiger verspätung
jeden moment starten könnte er kann bis
dahin dann doch noch mal eine frage an
sie haben gerade von kommunikativen
desaster gesprochen
deshalb möchte ich zu den aussagen von
spd altkanzler schröder kommen der ja
auch die situation nicht gerade leichter
macht mit aussagen wie zum beispiel dass
russland nicht der aggressor sei wie ist
das jetzt spielt so was irgendwie bei
gesprächen mit den amerikanern überhaupt
eine rolle
also
ich glaube aber muss trennen seine
tätigkeit für russische
energieunternehmen sind das eine darüber
könnte man viel sagen aber das will ich
gar nicht bewerten und ich glaube das
ist auch nicht im
mittelpunkt der politischen kontroverse
hier in deutschland und auch nicht im
mittelpunkt der kritik aus den usa
dass er aber diese position
diese exponierte position als
protagonist russische energieunternehmen
ehemaliger bundeskanzler jetzt dazu
nutzt sich politik zugunsten russlands
zu äußern in dieser auseinandersetzung
und in einer sehr
schwierigen art und weise wo er die
beweislast umgedreht hat und der ukraine
sehr über rasse vorgeworfen hat fand ich
sehr kontraproduktiv und es ist
eigentlich eine schwere belastung für
die deutsche außenpolitik und von daher
finde ich es zumindest nachvollziehbar
ich habe das nicht zu bewerten aber ich
finde es nachvollziehbar dass innerhalb
der spd eine gewisse absetzbewegung
kämpfer geworden ist wo sich eine
jüngere generation jetzt artikuliert und
sagt das ist nicht die position der spd
hier gibt es andere stimmen trotz allen
verständlichen ärger das ist keine
position der spd gerhard schröder hat
keine position erinnert der spd und das
gilt es zu trennen aber wir müssen damit
leben dass diese äußerungen natürlich in
der einen oder anderen weise weil er
bundeskanzler gewesen ist den
politischen
der politischen klasse nach wie vor zu
gerechnet werden vor allen dingen im
ausland und damit entsteht so ein prima
eindruck dass einerseits die
bundesregierung solidarität mit der
ukraine
immer wieder in den mittelpunkt ihrer
bemühungen stellt und gleichzeitig der
ehemalige bundeskanzler der ukraine sehr
blasse vorwirft
mazlum alten schreibt auf facebook warum
findet man keine einigung ohne einen
krieg es muss wohl doch zu der heutigen
zeit möglich sein eine lösung ohne krieg
zu finden nun wissen wir so weit ist es
zum glück doch noch lange nicht
allerdings es beschäftigt die menschen
und wie groß sehen sie die sorge dass
das eintreten könnte also ich finde es
durchaus nachvollziehbar dass leute in
das menschen in der bundesrepublik im
moment so gut weil die situation an der
ost ukraine verfolgen an der
ukrainisch-russischen grenze
ich glaube dass nato gebiet ist gut
geschützt niemand geht davon aus von
einem angriff auf das nato territorium
und das geht auch eine besondere art und
weise für deutschland also ich glaube es
wäre
alarmistisch jetzt von einer
kriegsgefahr
auszugehen die ganz europa erfassen
würde aber gleichzeitig ist es durchaus
berechtigt war er so geschätzt 120
tausend russische soldaten in der
ostukrainischen grenze zu fragen was ist
die intention der russischen seite und
das präsident putin bereit ist waffen
einzusetzen
das haben wir 2014 zur kenntnis nehmen
müssen und dementsprechend
dürfen ihn nicht verwundert sein wenn
wir so was wieder sehen und dass das
dann folgen haben wird die deutschland
auch betreffenden während eben
angesprochen über sanktion über
fluchtbewegungen prognosen gehen davon
aus dass mindestens fünf millionen
ukrainer das land verlassen würden und
die werden sie nie nahe osten in
bewegung setzen sondern sich auf dem weg
in die europäische union machen das ist
auch so eine facette die über die man im
moment nur spekulieren kann aber über
kurz oder lang werden wir die folgen
eines möglichen russischen angriffs auch
in deutschland sehen
und am scherben spricht das thema
sanktionen noch mal an er schreibt auf
youtube sanktionen sind wirtschaftskrieg
der startet vor allem normalen menschen
was man ja auch in anderen ländern wie
zum beispiel iran sieht die im seit
jahrzehnten mit sanktionen zu kämpfen
haben und wo es eben vor allem das volk
trifft
sie die frage noch mal wiederholen die
habe ich jetzt akustisch gar nicht
verstehen können es war es ging mir um
ein statement von scherben auf youtube
der eben geschrieben hat dass sanktionen
wirtschaftskrieg sind der vor allem
normalen menschen schadet würde das eben
vor allem eben die normalen menschen
treffen das volk treffen dass russische
und putin gar nicht so sehr wenn man
kann er den bogen oder seite spannend
und sehr durchaus
angemessen die wirksamkeit von
sanktionen normal zu hinterfragen ich
habe ja angedeutet es gibt da 2014 schon
schwere sanktionen gegen russland
der angestrebte effekt der erhoffte
effekt dass russland eine andere außen
und sicherheitspolitik einschlagen würde
ist nicht eingetreten jetzt kann man
argumentieren mehr sanktionen würden das
dann auslösen das gegenargument wäre das
ist für die russische auswahl
sicherheitspolitik eingepreist es gibt
die bereitschaft diese konsequenzen zu
tragen und damit wir die sinnhaftigkeit
von solche sanktion noch arme in frage
gestellt aber das ist zum gegenwärtigen
zeiten spekulation darüber kann man
nicht seriös gegeben aber ich glaube die
erwartung oder die befürchtung je nach
perspektive dass das eben auch den mann
auf der straße die frau auf der straße
treffen würde die ist nicht unbegründet
kleine noch mal kurz bei den sanktionen
kanzler scholz spricht ja von einem
sanktionskatalog möchte aber aus
taktischen gründen nichts sagen um
welche sanktionen es konkret sich
handeln würde us-präsident beiden ist ja
da ganz anderer meinung der sagt ja er
putin soll ganz genau wissen was dann
auf ihn zukommen würde und dann kann er
sich überlegen welche schritte er geht
was glauben sie wie sind die beiden da
heute zusammengekommen
das weiß ich nicht weil ich dabei
mir leuchtet das amerikanische argument
ziemlich ein weil wenn wir doch eins
gelernt haben aus den letzten
jahrzehnten des internationalen
krisenmanagements
ist dass es sich lohnt wenn ich das so
sagen darf das preisschild zu benehmen
also nicht im wagen zu bleiben sondern
nicht nur zu sagen es wird sanktion
geben sondern die konkreten ich glaube
jetzt immer kurz unterbrechen denn wenn
alle aufstehen dann kommen us-präsident
beiden und kanzler scholz wir schauen
uns die pressekonferenz an und reden
gleich weiter dankeschön für den moment
ich möchte zunächst bundeskanzler schulz
danken dass er nach washington gekommen
ist wir hatten die gelegenheit ein sehr
produktives treffen zu haben unserer
starb hat sich wahrscheinlich geändert
die erste halbe stunde haben wir
gemeinsam gesprochen das war ein
wirklich nützliches treffen was mich
erstaunt hat waren die gemeinsamen werte
die uns in unserer
führungsaufgabe gemeinsam
kennzeichnen und dass wir für die hürde
von arbeitern und beide
intensiv einsetzen und wir wollen
weiterhin die das bündnis vertiefen und
stärken und auch die partnerschaft
zwischen deutschland und den vereinigten
staaten ganz oben auf der agenda aber
heute natürlich unser gemeinsamer ansatz
um die das russische vorgehen gegen die
ukraine
zu besprechen und dagegen zu halten
haben wir vor allem gesprochen
deutschland verstanden zusammen mit
unseren bündnispartnern arbeiten eng
zusammen um eine diplomatische lösung
für diese situation zu bekommen die
diplomatie ist der beste weg nach vorn
da stimmen wir beide war ein und dass es
auch für russland unserer meinung nach
das beste wir sind ganz klar gewesen
dass wir in bous mit russland
zusammenarbeiten wollen und deutschland
will auch die in spannungen verringern
und den dialog norma dem format weiter
führen aber wenn russland die wahl
trifft weiter in die ukraine
einzelmaschinen dann stehen wir
natürlich bereit gemeinsam und in der
ganzen nato wir haben unsere enge
zusammenarbeit heute besprochen und wir
haben ein starkes sanktionspaket
entwickelt und wir haben die
entschlossenheit
dargestellt dass es schwere konsequenzen
geben wird in russland die territoriale
integrität und souveränität der ukraine
angreift und ich danke unseren
verbündeten und deutschland in europa an
dieser gemeinsamen
aufgabe mit zu arbeiten das kann jetzt
kein normales geschäft sein wenn
russland
einmarschiert und wir haben auch über
unsere verantwortung nach dem artikel 5
der nato gesprochen und zur versicherung
der
alliierten auf der östlich plage der
nato wir haben auch truppen geschickt um
die das bündnis zu verstärken ich danke
dem deutschen bundeskanzler
dafür gastgeber für amerikanische
truppen zu sein und die gastfreundschaft
des landes unseren
soldaten und soldaten gehen zu bringen
wir haben auch über china gesprochen
zusammen mit auch mit über russland und
anderen bewerbern in der zukunft und wir
haben gesagt dass jetzt zusammenarbeiten
werden auch in zukunft das
gelten für die nutzung
moderner technologien
dass die nicht genutzten sollen für
autoritarismus unterdrückung für
menschen wir haben
darüber gesprochen
die weitere integration europäischer
institutionen voranzutreiben
und für frieden in europa sand zu setzen
wäre auch über die gis 7 gesprochen die
deutsche präsidentschaft und wie dieses
forum demokratie in front bringen kann
um eine robuste kinder aufzubauen
angesichts der globalen
herausforderungen
von der partie bis zum thema wandel also
als bündnispartner in der nato oder als
partner über die europäische union als
führer in der g7 oder g20 wir haben eine
starke bilaterale beziehung deutschland
wie usa sind enge freunde und
verlässliche partner und wir können uns
aufeinander verlassen
es gibt kein problem der globalen von
globaler bedeutung für deutschland und
die usa nicht zusammenarbeiten
und stark zusammenarbeiten und wo wir
versuchen gemeinsam über unsere
anstrengungen lösungen zu finden und ich
freue mich darauf dass ich dass dies
jetzt die erste gelegenheit wahr wo wir
zusammenarbeiten und wir werden
sicherlich auch während des kommenden
jahres wenn dieses jahres und während
unserer weiteren
regierung kunsttreffen
zusammenstehen
es ist wichtig dass alle verbündeten
die usa und deutschland
die transatlantische partnerschaft
zwischen den usa und europa die nato
gemeinsam das gleiche sagen und
gemeinsam handeln und dass wir klar
gemacht haben wenn es zu einer
militärischen aggression gegen die
ukraine kommt dann wird es harte
gemeinsam vereinbarte und weitreichende
sanktionen geben es wird sehr sehr wohl
kosten für russland haben an solchen
schritt zu tun das ist klar gesagt und
von allen verstanden und vor allem
glaube ich ist die botschaft so
wiederholt abgegeben worden dass sie
auch in russland angekommen ist wichtig
ist dass wir jetzt auch intensiv daran
gearbeitet haben gemeinsame
vorbereitungen dafür zu treffen dass
sanktionen auch festgelegt werden können
wir wollen nicht damit anfangen wenn der
schlimmste fall eintritt an der
militärischen aggression gegen die
ukraine sondern können wir sofort
schnell und gemeinsam und vereint
handeln das werk wieder auf gleichzeitig
ist es wichtig dass wir all unsere
diplomatischen möglichkeiten nutzen ich
bin sehr froh über
eine große bereitschaft das alles mit
auf den weg zu bringen insbesondere die
bilateralen gespräche zwischen russland
und den usa
selbstverständlich die vereinbarung
gespräche die wir haben im rahmen des
nato russland formats das ist wichtig
auch damit russland versteht dass die
nato gemeinsam handelt und gemeinsam
vorbereitet ist nachdem viele jahre
nicht mehr richtig gespräch in gang
gekommen sind ist es ein gutes zeichen
dass sie jetzt stattfinden wo
kontroverse diskutiert werden aber dass
sie statt sich das gleiche gilt für die
frage der osze wo wieder diskutiert
werden muss über sicherheit in europa
auch das ist ein fortschritt so mühselig
wie es ist und so wenig da bisher
konkrete substanzielles herausgekommen
ist freuen wir uns darüber dass dieses
format wieder eine rolle spielt und
natürlich gilt das auch für die
gespräche zwischen der ukraine russland
frankreich und deutschland das nur mal
die format wir haben das es hat jahre
lang nicht mehr richtig viel leben
ausgestrahlt aber jetzt ist eine
situation da in berlin da wieder hart
miteinander diskutieren und das ist der
ansatzpunkt dafür dass wir auch wege
finden kann aus dieser konfliktsituation
heraus diese doppelstrategie aus klaren
ankündigung im hinblick auf sanktionen
die ergriffen werden falls es zu einer
militärischen aggression kommt und
gleichzeitig allen gesprächs formaten
die wir nutzen ist die
vielversprechendste die man in dieser
situation überhaupt ergreifen kann das
tun wir gemeinsam und wir stehen da fest
zusammen wir haben uns auch über viele
andere fragen und erhalten die für uns
jetzt wichtig sind insbesondere in
hinblick auf die g7 präsidentschaft der
bundesrepublik deutschland wo wir lange
miteinander zusammenarbeiten als
wirtschaft starke demokratie und wo wir
natürlich deshalb auch einen ganz
besonderen auftrag haben etwas
beizutragen für ein besseres
zusammenhalten der welt dazu zählt
insbesondere dass wir unverändert alles
dafür tun dass die bürgerinnen und
bürger dieses planeten geimpft werden
können nicht nur in unseren reichen
ländern wo wir noch den ein oder anderen
überzeugen müssen sondern auch in den
ländern wo viele sich gerne impfen
lassen würden aber nicht an die
impfstoffe herankommen und da sind die
initiativen die wir beide ergriffen
haben und die wir auch international
voranbringt von größter bedeutung
das gleiche gilt natürlich auch für die
frage der bekämpfung des
menschengemachten klimawandels ein
großes thema das uns alle umtreibt und
wo es offensichtlich ist dass wir nur
global gemeinsam erfolgreich werden sein
können denn das klima ist nun mal eine
sache die sich nicht an nationale
grenzen beschränkt wir haben als
industrienationen einen wichtigen
beitrag zu leisten mit unserem
technologischen möglichkeiten unseren
ökonomischen möglichkeiten die
voraussetzungen dafür zu schaffen dass
wir wohlstand haben können bei uns und
den anderen ländern der welt ohne dass
das klima geschädigt wird diese große
herausforderung ist für uns von großer
bedeutung und deshalb wollen wir auch
ein solches zusammenwirken in dieser
strategie mit voranbringen und über ein
klima club der gutwilligen in dieser
frage diskutieren der alle einlädt mit
das sind ein paar der punkte die wir
besprochen haben noch mal das gespräch
das wir persönlich und sehr intensiv war
bestätigt die gute zusammenarbeit
unserer länder die feste verbindung die
wir in unseren transatlantischen
partnerschaft haben und dass beide
länder sich aufeinander verlassen und
verlassen können
danke danke bundeskanzler chance
ich habe ein oder zwei
zum thema dieses nord stream gegen das
er lange zeit waren sie haben es jetzt
vorhin nicht namentlich genannt und ist
ganz hat das auch nicht getan haben sie
eine rückversicherung bekommen von
bundeskanzler chance dass deutschland
tatsächlich da auch den stecker zieht
bei diesem projekt falls russland
einmarschiert in der ruine haben sie
diskutiert was die definition eines
solches ist
ob die sanktionen die sie vorhaben und
die eu vorhaben und die us vorhaben nun
schon fertig geschnürt sind oder ob das
noch ausgearbeitet wird und ist denn in
der tat
also dass sie das nicht sagen wollen was
genau drin es ist das eine ausrede um
das deutschland vielleicht zum beispiel
die schrift maßnahmen nicht mittragen
würde
ich möchte zunächst antworten
in russland einmarschiert dann bedeutet
das dass truppen und panzer die grenze
zur ukraine überschreiten
und dann wird es eben kein nord stream
zwei mehr geben das wird dann zu ende
sein
aber wie werden sie das tun
wie genau soll das vonstatten gehen
denn das projekt liegen sie unter der
kontrolle von deutschland ich verspreche
ihnen behörden der lage sein das zu tun
ihre frage ich würde sehr klar sagen wir
haben uns intensiv vorbereitet darauf
dass wir die notwendigen sanktionen
konkret ergreifen können falls es zu
einer militärischen aggression gegen die
ukraine kommt und das ist ja notwendig
dass wir das tun damit auch von seiten
russlands klar verstanden wird dass es
hatte weitreichende maßnahmen geben wird
es gehört dazu dass wir nicht alle auf
dem tisch legen weil es notwendig ist
dass auch von seiten russlands
verstanden wird da könnte noch viel mehr
passieren als sie sich vielleicht selber
ausrechnen aber es ist gleichzeitig klar
dass wir gut vorbereitet sind dass eben
weitreichende maßnahmen seien wir werden
sie gemeinsam mit unseren alliierten
ergreifend gemeinsam auch mit den usa
und wir werden diese schritte auch alle
notwendigen schritte ergreifen und sie
können sicher sein es wird auch keine
maßnahmen geben bei denen wir
unterschiedlich agieren sondern wir
werden da einheitlich und zusammen
auftreten
das ist eine gute gelegenheit
amerika zu sagen dass wir vereint sein
denn das werk gemeinsam hatte werden
alle notwendigen schritte ergreifen
werden und alle von uns werden gemeinsam
die notwendigen schritte
würden sie heute versprechen dass sie
noch in zwei
beenden sie haben es nicht genannt wie
ich schon sagte wir handeln zusammen wir
sind absolut vereint und wir werden
keine unterschiedlichen schritte dann
greifen wenn die gleichen schritte
ergreifen und sie werden sehr hart für
russland sein
bundeskanzler
michael fischer dpa vielen dank herr
präsident zuerst eine frage an sie die
usa haben in den letzten jahren immer
wieder
schwere waffen in die ukraine geliefert
deutschland schließt das kategorisch aus
als zuletzt noch 5000 schutzhelme an die
ukraine geliefert meinen sie nicht dass
die nato auch in diesem punkt
geschlossen handeln sollte sprich dass
deutschland als stärkster europäischer
nato partner auch schwere waffen in die
ukraine liefern sollte die waffen die
die ukraine auch von deutschland
erbittet und zur nord co2 würde ich
gerne von ihnen wissen finden sie nicht
angesichts der russischen bedrohung dass
deutschland jetzt schon seine position
zur nord stream zwei überdenken sollte
und eine dritte frage wenn sie erlauben
es hat in den in den vergangenen tagen
wochen sehr scharfe kritik in us medien
auch aus dem kongress an deutschland
gegeben die verlässlichkeit deutschlands
als print bündnispartner ist in frage
gestellt worden
haben sie verständnis für diese kritik
ist deutschland aus ihrer sicht noch ein
verlässlicher partner und
herr bundeskanzler an sie auch noch mal
die nachfrage zur 22 sie sagen alle
optionen liegen auf dem tisch sie nennen
nord stream zwei nicht beim namen
glauben sie nicht dass sie wenn sie es
beim namen nennen würde den vertrauen
zurückgewinnen könnten westlichen
bündnispartnern und auch hier in den usa
dem bergrecht setzt ist nicht
erforderlich das vertrauen
zurückzugewinnen er hat das volle
vertrauen der usa deutschland ist unser
wichtigster verbündeter in doch in der
welt es gibt keine zweifel an der
partnerschaft deutschlands
und eine der größten
zahler für die ukraine war deutschland
und dort und hat große wirtschaftliche
hilfe geleistet und sie haben so viele
fragen stellt ich kann mir nicht alle
erinnern aber
dass die amerikanischen medien sagen
deutschland wären nicht zuverlässig
deutschland das komplett vollständig
ganz klar verlässlich habe überhaupt
keinen zweifel an deutschland
sind eng verbunden mit den vereinigten
staaten die transatlantische
partnerschaft zwischen deutschland um
den usa zählt zu den ganz ganz wichtigen
konstanten der deutschen politik die
auch für die zukunft von allergrößter
bedeutung sind und sie können sich
darauf verlassen dass das auch in der
zukunft immer ganz ganz vorne bei den
prioritäten ist wir sind im rahmen der
nato das land das im kontinentalen
europa den größten aufwand treibt für
die militärische kraft die wir bereit
stellen in diesem zusammenhang und die
finanziellen budget mittel die dafür
mobilisiert werden und wir sind auch das
land das ein sehr sehr großen mit den
usa streiten wir uns immer noch darum
werden den größten teil leistet aber
einen sehr großen teil der finanziellen
hilfen für die ukraine zur verfügung
stellt es sind seit 214 etwa zwei
milliarden dollar die direkt aus dem
deutschen finanzierungsrahmen kommen und
über die europäische union sind es noch
mal 3,8 milliarden also richtig viel
finanzielle mittel zur ökonomischen
stabilisierung die wir beigetragen haben
und wir sind auch weiter bereit diesen
beitrag zu leisten und deshalb ist dass
die unverbindliche partnerschaft
zwischen den usa und deutschland die
wichtig ist zu der dann auch zählt dass
wir jetzt im hinblick auf die schwierige
situation an der grenze der ukraine
wegen der russischen truppen sehr klar
gesagt haben wir werden bei den
sanktionen komplett einvernehmlich
agieren
der präsident noch mal die nachfrage
auch die waffenlieferung ist das aus
ihrer sicht in ordnung dass nato partner
da unterschiedlich handeln und zudem
zwei auch noch mal die frage
halten sie die aktuelle positionierung
in der jetzigen situation angesichts der
russischen bedrohung für in ordnung
es gibt keine zweifel
bei den amerikanern dass deutschland ein
unglaublich zuverlässiger partner ist
und bündnispartner ist und eine der
führenden mächte innerhalb der nato ist
das erste zweiter gedanke dass nord
stream zwei
vorangehen würde mit einem einmarsch der
russen dass wir nicht passieren
wall street journal sabina
vielen dank herr präsident
auf der grundlage dessen was jetzt
wissen glauben sie dass präsident putin
einer inflation der ukraine vom ende des
winters auto sehen wird und was sagen
sie den kasten der orkan hatte ihn auch
keiner sind
müssen sie besorgt
ich hatte viele gespräche mit
den russen und auch insbesondere mit
putin ich weiß nicht
was er tun glaubt oder ob er weiß was er
tun will
vielleicht merkt er das ist ein großer
fehler wäre
in die ukraine 1 maschinen das hätte
eine stimme ausdrücken für europa und
rest der welt und der preis wäre sehr
hoch ich war ganz deutlich und offen
gegenüber präsident putin an telefon und
persönlich gegenüber wir werden
wirtschaftliche sanktionen ergreifen und
er wird sehr viel zahlen müssen und das
wird auf andere ausgegraben auf uns auf
die europäer aber es wird eine sehr
starke auswirkung auf seine
volkswirtschaft haben ich weiß nicht was
ich weiß ist er in einer position jetzt
dass er praktisch
einmarschieren kann
der boden um kiew ist sehr gefroren er
hat die möglichkeit was er machen wird
weiß ich nicht ich glaube nicht dass
irgendjemand das jetzt weiß
die amerikaner in der ukraine sollten
die das land verlassen ich denke das
wäre vernünftig ich spreche jetzt nicht
über die diplomat nicht spreche mit die
amerikaner die dort sind die zivilisten
ich möchte nicht dass sie ins kreuzfeuer
geraten dafür gibt es keinen grund
und ich denke sie können das dann
verlassen
bundeskanzler schulz können sie bitte
sagen was deutschland konkret tun kann
um die energieabhängigkeit poster zu
verringern und was können sie sagen
inwieweit
verringert sich die option
europas zu reagieren auf die krise die
das mit sich dass endras vielleicht
einmal die gute botschaft vorweg
deutschland hat sich im rahmen seiner
strategie zur bekämpfung des
menschengemachten klimawandels
entschieden in ganz kurzer frist also
mittlerer frist die 25 jahren komplett
aus der nutzung von öl kohle und gas
auszusteigen
2045 wird deutschland spätestens co2
neutrale wirtschaften und zwar als eines
der leistungsfähigsten industrieländer
der welt wir denken ja bei all diesen
rohstoffen immer an die heizung zu hause
und das autofahren aber es geht ja auch
um industrielle produktion wie man stahl
herstellt wie chemie gemacht wird wie
das hergibt mit der zementherstellung
und das alles umzustellen große
industrielle prozesse neu zu
organisieren in dieser kurzen zeit dass
das was wir uns vorgenommen haben
deshalb werden noch in diesem jahr weit
reichende entscheidung getroffen die
dazu beitragen dass wir uns kapazitäten
der nutzung von windenergie
offshore windenergie onshore und
solarenergie auszubauen auch das netz
auszubauen und eine deutschland gezogen
aber auch welt gezogene strategie zu
entwickeln zur nutzung von wasserstoff
was zentral dafür ist dass wir die
industriellen prozesse die heute öl oder
gas verwenden anders organisieren können
die industrie ist dazu gewählt und wir
machen das mit dem zusammen aber das
wird wahrscheinlich die größte
industrielle modernisierung sein die in
deutschland stattfindet seit über 100
jahren mit den guten chancen dass wir
damit auch technologien entwickeln
können die anderswo in der welt
eingesetzt werden können denn
letztendlich hängen wir dass die
klimawandel betrifft ja miteinander
zusammen im übrigen ist es so dass bei
der heutigen energiemix sich um ein
viertel des energiemixes handelt der
gast zu tun hat und davon ist nur ein
teil russisches gas ein großer teil
kommt aus norwegen und aus den
niederlanden
und selbstverständlich ist es für uns
ganz ganz wichtig dass wir gleichzeitig
infrastrukturen etablieren die für uns
die möglichkeit schaffen dass wir alle
optionen immer haben und in jeder zeit
sicher agieren können also da müssen sie
sich keine sorgen mache sorgen machen
müssen sich einige die vielleicht zu
sehr als rohstofflieferanten auf diese
fossilen ressourcen setzen denn wenn
weltweit der weg auch gegangen mit dem
wir gehen sich auf erneuerbare energien
zu konzentrieren dann wird dieses
instrument ökonomisch alt gar nicht mehr
zur verfügung stehen
der winkel
herr präsident ich hätte ganz gerne
frage gestellt zum thema energie europa
und deutschland ist sehr viel stärker
von russischem gas abhängig als andere
regionen der welt sie haben den
europäischen verbündeten
versprochen mit er den tigers zu helfen
er den chicas ist allerdings teuer steht
auch nicht in diesen mengen zur
verfügung das russisches gas ersetzen
könnte ich hätte ganz gerne gewusst wie
sie den europäern in einem konfliktfall
mit russland wirklich helfen können ist
das ein leeres versprechen oder was
können sie tatsächlich anbieten
zudem kauft kaufen die usa in russland
für viele milliarden öl jedes jahr ich
hatte ganz gerne gewusst ob diese will
einkäufe auch teil des sanktionspaket es
sind was derzeit auf dem tisch liegt
gegen russland und der bundeskanzler
auch zum thema flüssiggas ist ja auch
fracking gas dass es in deutschland sehr
umstritten wie sehr passt der bezug von
lg gaz als option und alternative zu
ihrem ziel ein klima club zu gründen ist
es die einfach in der abwägung bessere
alternative zu russischen partners
[Musik]
lasso wie folgt antworten wir schauen
uns möglichkeiten an wo es wie wir und
verloren das gas durch aus russland
durch flüssiggas essen können wir
überlegen wie wir das tun können wir
aber damit unseren freunden auf der
ganzen welt wir denken dass wir einen
großen anteil ersetzen können der
verloren gehen würde aber
wir dürfen nicht vergessen russland muss
in der lage sein sein gas und öl zu
verkaufen
russland hängt sehr stark in bei den
eigenen finanzen davon ab dass das
einzige was sie haben um es zu
exportieren und wenn die das nicht mehr
exportieren
dann tut das weh das ist keine
einbahnstraße das auch konsequenzen für
russland wir schauen uns an was wir tun
können um
die sofortigen verluste von gas in
europa ausgleichen können falls die
auftreten und wir arbeiten der schon
seit einiger zeit raten dass wir eng mit
den vereinigten staaten von amerika und
sobald man sich persönlich in dieser
frage zusammenarbeiten dass wir uns auf
alle situationen vorbereiten das gehört
ja auch dazu wenn wir sagen wir bereiten
alle möglichen sanktionen vor dann
müssen wir ja selber in der lage sein
gewissermaßen auch geht derzeit
handlungsfähig zu bleiben das geschieht
was die frage der nutzung von energie
betrifft ist es zunächst mal so dass das
meiste allen sie das auf der welt
genutzt wird aus natürlichen gast
besteht und auch das glaube ich gehört
zu der debatte liegt dazu dass die
langfristige perspektive betrifft habe
ich ja schon gesagt worum es geht wir
werden unsere wirtschaft im wesentlichen
dort wo gase genutzt werden müssen auf
wasserstoff umstellen und das wird ein
prozess sein der schneller vor sich geht
als man hier das wollte sich vorstellen
mögen da aber eine gute zukunft für uns
alle mit sich bringen
[Musik]
die antwort ist ja
das war die pressekonferenz von
us-präsident beiden und kanzler scholz
zu dessen antrittsbesuch in den usa und
es ging eben wie erwartet vor allem um
den ukraine russland konflikt ich möchte
gerne noch mal mit nina niebergall
unserer usa korrespondentin in
washington sprechen die die
pressekonferenz selbstverständlich auch
verfolgt hat nina wir haben vorhin
darüber gesprochen dass das ansehen
deutschlands in den usa durchaus
angekratzt war weil es eben so viele
stimmen gab die gesagt haben deutschland
ist in dieser krise kein verlässlicher
bündnispartner
würdest du an sehen würdest du sagen
dass das ansehen jetzt wieder
hergestellt ist
das ist die große frage also die beiden
joe biden und olaf scholz haben sich
größte mühe gegeben
joe biden hat davon gesprochen dass hier
freunde zusammen gekommen sind dass es
keinen anlass gebe an der bündnistreue
von deutschland zu zweifeln olaf scholz
es zwischendurch ins englische
gewechselt hat versucht die amerikaner
und amerikanerinnen
direkt anzusprechen also damit haben sie
sicherlich versucht vertrauen wieder
herzustellen
aber eine sache die es natürlich
irgendwie noch offen geblieben
und da geht es wiederum um nord stream
22 beiden hat sehr klar gesagt wenn
russland in die ukraine einmarschiert
dann wird es keinen nord stream 2 geben
aber es hat eben nur joe biden gesagt
olaf scholz ist weiterhin im wagen
geblieben im prinzip bedeutet das sehr
sicher dass das beide dahinter stehen
aber er hat es eben wieder nicht ganz
klar kommuniziert er bleibt bei seiner
haltung zu sagen es liegt alles auf dem
tisch aber möchte nicht dass ist die
deutsche strategie deutschland möchte
nicht putin sagen was sie genau vorhaben
was sie für es asse im ärmel haben
während die usa ist eben sehr klar sagen
möchte und diese strategie die haben
beide nun scholz konsequent auch auf
dieser pressekonferenz nebeneinander
stehend verfolgt aber es war natürlich
etwas skurril dass joe biden sehr klar
ausgesprochen hat was mit nord stream 2
passieren wird nämlich die pipeline wird
dann im falle einer invasion nicht in
betrieb genommen während olaf scholz
nicht klar ausgesprochen hat genau es
war eine völlig absurde situation der
eine steht da und sagt natürlich wird es
dann nicht passieren und der andere hält
es völlig im wagen und fühlt sich da
weiterhin ins unklar
warum hat er das gemacht ich war eltmann
wir können nur spekulieren aber es wie
du sagst es war tatsächlich eine etwas
seltsame situation
genau wir können nur spekulieren
tatsächlich ist es so ich hatte es
gerade schon erwähnt dass eben die
beiden länder hier unterschiedliche
strategien verfolgen
deutschland möchte sich offensichtlich
bewusst bedeckt halten um
putin nicht preiszugeben was zu welchen
mitteln man greifen könnte
wirtschaftlichen mitteln im falle einer
invasion und die usa verfolgt hier eben
eine andere strategie sie wollen ganz
klar machen was putin befürchten muss
wenn er eben russische truppen in der
ukraine einmarschieren lässt und ja
diese beiden strategien die die lage
weiterhin auf dem tisch heute bei dieser
pressekonferenz es hat eben wie du schon
gesagt hast einen etwas skurrilen
anstrich und damit möchten wir dir danke
sagen nina niebergall usa
korrespondentin vom zdf in washington
vielen dank für deine informationen und
deine einschätzung des baltikums
und diese situation eben in dieser
pressekonferenz war tatsächlich so
skurril dass ich die frage gerne auch
nochmal an markus kaim von der stiftung
wissenschaft und politik weitergeben
möchte wie kann das denn sein
tatsächlich präsident biden hat doch in
aller klarheit gesagt wenn russland in
die ukraine einmarschiert ist dieses
projekt nord stream zwei so gut wie tot
und am olaf scholz steht daneben und
bestätigt das nicht
naja der amerikanische präsident hat uns
in der sanktionspaket klauen lassen also
es gibt eigentlich nur eine mögliche
antwort darauf
bundeskanzler scholz hat zugesichert
dass im fall des falles not film zwei
beerdigt wird das wen er zum
gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt gegenüber der
deutschen öffentlichkeit nicht so
kommunizieren aber in der sache
überrascht uns das nicht wirklich er hat
es offensichtlich dem amerikanischen
präsidenten so zugesichert hinzu kommt
dass die usa sofern noch insofern einen
wirksamen hebel selber in der hand haben
weil aufgrund einer
deutsch-amerikanischen vereinbarung vom
verein juno die sanktionen die der
amerikanische kongress
erlassen hart gegen firmen die sich an
der tür zur halle beteiligen nur
ausgesetzt sind sie können jederzeit
aktiviert werden und dementsprechend
hatte der amerikanische präsident schon
etwas für sich als er lächelnd sagte wir
werden das schon
beenden können das können sie und
offensichtlich sind die die planung und
die zusicherung viel weiter an die
öffentlichkeit durchgesickert sind und
ich glaube dass der amerikanische
präsident das so gesagt hat aus seinem
naturell geschuldet hat anruf
wie soll man sagen
mit information ein wenig loser
umzugehen als das andere
regierungspolitiker tun und ich glaube
so ist es zu dieser situation gekommen
so wird es voll gewesen sein dass es
gerade mehr als deutlich gewann jetzt
stellen wir uns mal vor dass russlands
präsident putin ebenso wie wir diese pk
verfolgt hat und eben auch die
statements und antworten sich angehört
hat was denken sie wie ist das jetzt
alles bei putin angekommen ich kenne sei
wie es bei mir angekommen ist ich kann
nicht über den pro-russischen
präsidenten
spekulieren ich finde die amerikaner im
etwas mit ihrer strategie für sich das
signal dass sie aussehen wirkt
kraftvoller es burg entschlossener es
wird wird strategischer es wirkt
insofern stark am ball ist die wirkung
auf die andere seite
ganz klar in rechnung stellt und es
wirkt dadurch entschlossener
und auch politischer weil es die
grundlage für weitere gespräche seien
für weitere gespräch bietet nun gegen
die deutsche position auch wenn sie in
der sache vielleicht gar nicht so weit
davon entfernt wie wir gerade darüber
gesprochen doch merkwürdig
kleinmütig leise
unentschlossen ihr führungsschwach
vogtmann punkt ist nicht dass ich das
dem bundeskanzler unterstellen will
sondern ich sagen oh wie es braucht und
dadurch entsteht dieser ungute eindruck
die unentschlossenheit und leisetreterei
deutschen politik
es muss weitere gespräche geben und es
wird die auch geben mit vielen
verschiedenen beteiligten in den
unterschiedlichen konstellationen und
das wird in den folgenden tagen auch
passieren also pendeldiplomatie wenn man
so will an allen fronten laura rosinus
gibt uns da mal einen überblick
nach seinem besuch in washington bei
präsident beiden geht es für kanzler
scholz direkt weiter am dienstag begrüßt
er die präsidenten von frankreich und
polen zum austausch im kanzleramt kaum
sind sie dann weg folgen am donnerstag
die regierungschefs von lettland estland
und litauen so manövriert sich berlin
ins zentrum der verhandlung vor allem
mit der wiederbelebung des normandy
formats es bringt unter vermittlung von
frankreich und deutschland hochrangige
regierungsvertreter von ukraine und
russland an einen tisch das nächste
treffen ist ebenfalls für donnerstag im
kanzleramt geplant
verkaufen die letzte frage für diesen
abend und mit dem ausblick den wir jetzt
gerade hatten was muss passieren damit
es eine lösung in diesem konflikt gibt
und gleichzeitig alle beteiligten ihr
gesicht wahren können die frage ist was
sie meint die lösung sagen mein sie den
rückzug der russischen streitkräfte von
der krim und die rückabwicklung der
aktion wollen sie eine
verhandlungslösung für die ost ukraine
das halte ich nicht für realistisch in
den gegenwärtigen gegebenheiten was mein
moment erreichen könnte wäre eine
deeskalation an der
ukrainisch-russischen grenze einen
truppenverlegung wieder das große kern
und hinein und entsprechende zusicherung
über trends bei transparenz maßnahmen
vertrauens und sicherheitsgründe
maßnahme ich glaube die grundsätzlich
unterschiedlichen ordnungsvorstellungen
zwischen rußland einerseits und dem
besten andererseits wie die sicherheit
europas zu organisieren ist die wäre
eine fortbestehen und die artikulieren
sich in besonderer art und weise an
diesem zwischen europa also an
denjenigen ländern die nicht mitglied
der nato und nicht mitglied der
europäischen union sind und gleichzeitig
eben den bannkreis russlands hinter sich
lassen wollen
vielen dank herr kaim für ihre
einschätzung für ihre hintergründe und
für ihre informationen machen sind gut
ja und auch in vielen dank für
das zuschauen fürst dabei sein ich
möchte noch eine meinung aus der
community vorlesen wasili schreibt auf
facebook wir wollen keinen krieg sucht
die diskussion einen dritten weltkrieg
überlebt niemand niemand braucht
atombomben oder atomraketen dialog
frieden für alle menschen dieser welt
das ist die lösung in diesem sinne es
spät geworden heute trotzdem noch einen
schönen abend